welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and moon knight trapped mark
spector and steven grant in an egyptian
themed hospital psych ward filled with
parallels to their waking life and the
more we re-watch the scene the more we
realize that everything we see like in
willy wonka's factory our delicious
easter eggs from earlier episodes and
also like willy wonka's factory it's all
a creepy death trap this is kind of
strange yeah strange charlie but it's
fun so i'm gonna re-analyze this
sequence to break down all the new stuff
that we found and by the way we still
have a few remaining moon knight
inspired tomb of the moon god shirts
available at newrockstarsmerch.com be
sure to grab one before they run out so
episode 4 is titled the tomb referring
to the lost tomb of alexander the great
where stephen finds amit sushapti but it
may also describe what mark and
stephen's hospital reality is at least
for the purposes of this story like you
could certainly interpret mark and
steven's whole journey of this series as
a voyage through the two watts the
underworld through the field of reeds
and that now upon mark getting shot he
descends into the place where the
indiana entombed deities like amit
konchu and tuaret however the way people
entombed in sarcophagi in this hospital
don't stay entombed this could lead to a
tawarat assisted rebirth mark first
enters this realm after getting shot in
the chest falling backward into shallow
water but then descending in a much
deeper water the bullet holes now
vanished but the frame inverts so that
it looks like he's actually ascending
upward and then we find ourselves in the
low budget tomb buster movie where dr
steven grant more so resembles arthur
harrow with similar hair in the use of a
compass and like in raiders the lost ark
they find the remains of a past
colleague and then they focus on the
statue of the aztec moon deity
koyashoutki its bust split into several
faces like the statue of mark in the
closing credits crawley shows up here
holding out his hat the way his hat was
always at his feet for tips and i put it
out before how the bingo numbers that he
calls out plus the ones that are stamped
on mark's card most of these are not
accurate bingo numbers since b numbers
are 1 through 15 etcetera etcetera for
the rest of the numbers you would not
have a b22 or a b83 you'd only have as
high as b15 he also says t16 and there
is no t in bingo but clearly these are
inaccurate by design it's a reflection
of how everything we see in this
hospital is meant to be surreal i'm
actually more interested in what crawley
says if you listen closely come on
everyone don't fall asleep on me now
it's just getting good don't fall asleep
another parallel to stephen's fears of
drifting out of consciousness and his
difficulty distinguishing between his
waking life and dreams then we see a man
playing with a rubik's cube nearly
finishing the white side as we saw in
steven's flat then there's a woman who
looks a lot like dylan sitting behind
that guy now dylan's name might even
come from how harrows colt listens to
bob dylan's every grain of sand the
orderly bobby has jell-o the same colors
as a powder bowl steven found in the
mummification room now bobby and billy
who is the guy pushing us in the
wheelchair currently were of course the
directives fitzgerald and kennedy those
names being kinda silly as the middle
and last name of john fitzgerald kennedy
u.s president and bobby and billy are
the names of the orderlies in the jeff
lemire comics donna shows up holding the
plush scarab that we saw in the museum
gift shop in episode one she says be a
bit up here if he pulled some bloody o's
now we know from mark's card that
crowley has already called o67 o55 and
011 and soon we'll say oh 47 and oh 73.
so crowley has called plenty of bloody
o's now that clock on the wall has a
hand in the shape of conscious staff
with a crescent moon at the end and
despite us hearing ticking throughout
all of this the second hand never
actually moves jesus
then of course the carton of cupcakes
just like the von deroman van from
episode one now i love this the schedule
on the dry erase board includes a daily
zoo visit again not something mental
patients would actually be allowed to do
but perhaps a nod to the animalistic
deities that are also being kept in this
facility there is a gardener like the
one in harrow's compound in episode two
then there's this woman whom some are
asking if she might be the forger from
episode three but she is not it's a
different actress but this woman
sketches a hummingbird just like the one
in the episode two nature footage this
hummingbird has conscious skull head now
then on the whiteboard are other photos
of foreign locales just like the
postcard steven has been receiving but
the crazier detail those abstract
drawings pinned to the board are
actually the same murals on the walls of
harrow's compound in episode 2. now i
have talked about gus's fishbowl except
there is no water in this bowl he's just
suspended frozen and when you look at
the stacks of those books it includes
royal necropolis and black pharaohs that
second one perhaps another clue pointing
to pharaoh rama tut who might be
jonathan magers and i know you might say
well the pharaohs were all egyptian no
there actually is a history of darker
skinned pharaohs in egyptian history and
jonathan majors could have just snuck in
that history and there was that kang
easter egg that we confirmed on the back
of that kid's jacket but also there is a
book with s campanelli episode six
episode six on a book this looks like a
nod to stephen campanelli a cameraman
known for his steadicam work and long
time collaborator with clint eastwood
maybe episode 6 of this series will be
shot by stephen camanelli or might use
his steadicam style now you've probably
noticed that new rockstars is growing
we've introduced new hosts new show
formats and the volume of videos we make
every week is higher than ever and we've
got a new show starting next week that
we think you're going to love the break
room is a daily live show broadcasting
from our actual break room at new
rockstars hq in southern california
every weekday afternoon it'll be
covering all the nerd news from the day
reacting to the latest releases
previewing videos you're going to see on
this channel hosting some special guests
and most important interacting with you
the viewers this live stream show will
feature some familiar new rockstars
faces tom ebeck told jessica clemons
producer brandon and you may even see
empty whitney me or even villa molina on
there every once in a while now this
will not be replacing any of the content
you love on new rockstars it's going to
be extra new content in a new format on
the channel the break room being live is
gonna let the host interact with you in
real time reacting to your theories
disagreeing with your hot takes and
sharing and the joy of geeking out over
our favorite properties so join new
rockstars live in the break room every
weekday here on youtube and if you
missed seeing the show live don't worry
you'll be able to catch the replays
right here on the channel so leila
appears in the same suite that she ate
in episode 3 from the forger and we
pointed out how she has that bandage
with the scarlet scarab on it a nod to
her possible lineage as the scarlet
scarab the egyptian protector fighting
against the invaders in the marvel
comics and an even crazier detail is if
you look closely at layla's hands
earlier in the episode like when she's
clutching the edge of the cliff while
fighting the heka priest that same pinky
finger already has a band-aid on it mark
falls on his face due to the foot
harness just as he does from his bed in
episode two and falling on the same side
of his face is it in the alps in episode
one and he has this moon knight action
figure which some are asking if this
could be a skeletor action figure it's
not the arms the torso of the feet they
are all different despite skeletor being
hooded this hood actually looks like it
was added on top of another action
figure and the whole thing painted over
white regardless it is weird that there
is a moon knight action figure at all
considered in the mcu moon knight is not
really a known branded entity but my
favorite new detail is in harrow's
office this whole set with its tall
ceilings its columns its brick arches
folks this is the same attic room in
harrow's compound from episode 2 when
stephen and layla fled the jackal they
used the same set and they painted over
it white then of course there's a
painting of the alpine village from
episode 1 the vhs tape of toonbuster has
the tagline when deeper in here steven
grant has no fear then dr harrow taps
his pen on his glasses evoking the pen
clicking analysts in the jeff lemire
comics hero quotes the villain from the
toonbuster movie no tree can ascend to
the light of heaven if it doesn't
descend to the depths of hell which is a
paraphrase from a quote the
psychoanalyst and philosopher carl young
spoke about enlightenment being a
product of confronting one's inner
demons harrow then unfolds a
handkerchief that looks a lot like his
head scarf in episode 2 but it might be
a different part of the stitching than
what we see a housefly lands on steven's
hand which feels like a psycho reference
but also might reflect mark's corpse
status connecting to crawley's other
line i can smell it
[Music]
also nearby are more canopic jars the
same ones in the mummification process
used by the heka priest now as mark
flees down the hallway the imagery
matches the shots and the credits of the
storage facility when it switches to the
hospital and the lamps swing back and
forth these are actually the same lamps
from mark's hotel at the end of episode
two but listen closely here
that creaking sound and the way this
hallway tilts just seems like we could
be within an old wooden ship which
brings us back to this episode being
titled the tomb we know this season will
later feature a large egyptian vessel
through a purple desert landscape all of
this could be mark and steven's
temporary entombing in a metaphorical
sarcophagus on this vessel as they
complete the voyage through the field of
reeds and like all egyptian sarcophagi
an ornately decorated tomb one designed
to be the ultimate test for this soul as
it faces its judgment and ultimately i
think rather than this being a
transition into the permanent afterlife
i really think tawaret was presented at
the end of this episode as a sign of
hope because as the goddess of
protection fertility and rebirth draw it
could be their guide to resurrection
follow me on instagram and twitter hey
boss follow the new rockstar subscribing
to rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you